اذا من المتوقع بحسب تصريحات للمكتب
الاعلامي لمعبر باب الهوى ان تدخل بعد
قليل مساعدات انسانيه من الامم المتحده
تسلم الى المنظمات الشريكه مع الامم
المتحده حتى يصار الى تسليمها للمتضررين
من الزلزال عبر المنظمات العامله داخل
سوريا
والحقيقه
المتضررون من الزلزال يعيشون اوضاعا صعبه
في ظل انخفاض درجات الحراره عددهم كبير
ويتوزعون في مختلف مناطق محافظه ادلب
لنتعرف على اوضاعهم اكثر يمكن ان نستضيف
عبد السلام معنا محمود احد المسؤولين في
فريق ملهم يعطيكم العافيه حدثنا حدثنا عن
اوضاع المتضررين الذين تلقونهم والذين
تسلمونهم المساعدات
سلمتموهم مساعده خلال الايام الماضيه
واليوم في الحقيقه الاف النازحين الان
يفترشون مراكز الايواء يفترشون المدارس
يفترشون الخيم الكثير منهم لا زال يبحث عن
خيم او مراكز لتحتضنهم وسط هذا البرد
الشديد كما نعلم درجات الحراره طول
الاسبوع الماضي الصفر وما دون الصفر في
ظلها هذه الطقس البارق ما زال النازحين
يعيشون دون اي مساعدات امميه دون اي
مساعدات انسانيه ترقى لحجم الكارثه التي
حلت على المنطقه
وفي مدينه ادلب ايضا هناك عدد من المخيمات
ويقصدونها حسب ما راينا صباح اليوم يقصدها
المتضررون من مسافات بعيده حتى من مدينه
جنديرس الا يكلف الانتقال عبر هذه
المسافات الطويله المتضررين الكثير من
الجهد والتعب يعني لماذا لا تتوجهون اليهم
الحقيقه كميه الكارثه اكبر بكثير من حجم
امكانيات المنظمات العمل في شمال السوري
المنظمات العامه في شمال سوريا غير مهيئه
مثل حجم هذه الكارثه خاصه ان القطاع
الاغازي القطاع الانساني منهك طوال
السنوات الماضي طوال عشر سنوات الماضي كل
فتره ماساه جديده كل فتره مشكله جديده تقع
على الشعب السوري المؤسسات الانسانيه
منهكه طوال هذه السنه الماضيه اتت هذه
الكارثه لتعم كل شمال السوري المنظمات غير
قادره على تحمل كل هذا العبء لوحدها وتركت
المنظمات وترك الشعب السوري الوحيدا لذلك
ضاف عبء اضيف عبء على الكاهن منظمات
السوريه انا بقيت وحيد امام هذه المصيبه
النازحون يبحثون عن اي اي اماكن تقويهم
مثل المدارس مثل تجمعات يبحثون عن اي مكان
خاصه بعد ان فقدوا مدنها مدن مثل جنديرس
او مثل حارم فقدت البنيه التحتيه فقدت
القومات الحياه لا كهرباء لا اتصالات
خدمات الطبيه شبه منعدمه في تلك المناطقوا
يبحثون عن الاماكن فقط تقويهم وتعزلهم عن
هذا البرد الموجود شكرا لك محمود احد
المسؤولين في فريق ملهم بطبيعه الحال
التحدي الكبير الذي يعيشه المتضررون
الحقيقه هو ان عدد المنازل المتصدعه والتي
يطالب الدفاع المدني السوري سكانها بعدم
العوده اليها عدد كبير جدا وحقيقه لا توجد
ارقام واضحه حول هذه المنازل هنا في معبر
باب الهوى ايضا عبد السلام هناك
اناس اخرون يعيشون اوضاع صعبه هؤلاء الذين
ينتظرون وصل وصول جثث ذويهم من الجانب
التركي من اللاجئين السوريين الذين قضوا
في المدن التركيه هؤلاء ما زالوا ينتظرون
هنا ايضا اي خبر عن ذويه وصولهم الى هذه
النقطه ليتم نقلهم بعد ذلك
ويتم دفنهم في مدنهم وبلداتهم في محافظه
ادلب في ريف حلب ايضا معبر باب الهوى كان
قد تحدث عن ان اكثر من الف شخص
يصل وصلت جثامين اكثر من الف شخص
ويتم تسليمها الى ذويهم وطبعا تم نقلهم
الى المناطق داخل سوريا لكي يتم دفنهم
والعدد مرشح للازدياد طبعا لان حركه وصول
لان حركه وصول
حركه وصول هؤلاء ما تزال مستمره بطبيعه
الحال هنا هنا ايضا اهلهم وذويهم ينتظرون
ايضا وقد تطول حقيقه فتره وانتظارهم لان
هذه العمليه عمليه التسليم
السوريين يبدو انها معقده في الجانب
التركي وقبل
فتره نشر باب الهوى عن تعليمات تخص نقل
السوريين الذين قضوا نتيجه الزلزال في
تركيا قال بان عليهم ان يتوجهوا الى مقبره
الريحانيه في الجانب التركي من الحدود حتى
يتم توثيق اسمائهم ومن ثم يتم نقلهم عبر
معبر باب الهوى الى داخل سوريا المساعدات
الانسانيه ربما تصل في
خلال
الاوقات القريبه القادمه وبحسب المكتب
الاعلامي لباب الهوى فانها تحوي على
مستلزمات خيام وهذه المستلزمات تبدو
ضروريه حقيقه في ظل عدم قدره المتضررين
والذين تصدعت بيوتهم على العوده اليها
لانه حتى اللحظه هناك فقط مطالبات لهم
بعدم العوده اليها يبدو ان هناك سياره
وصلت الان وهي تن
جثث السوريين من داخل تركيا يهرع الناس
فورا الى السيارات القادمه يا ينظرون الى
الجثث حقيقه الموقف صعب جدا يعني هناك
اناس لم لم يلتقوا بدويهم
بسواء كانوا اخوه لهم او اقرباء
لم يلتقوا بهم منذ سنتين او ثلاثه هم
يتسلمون جثامينهم الان
يلقون يعني النظر على عده جثث حتى يعرفوا
اياها تعود لاقرباء لهم هذا هذا المشهد
حقيقه صعب جدا ونحن نعينه هنا منذ ايام
بطبيعه الحال كنا نتحدث عن اصحاب البيوت
المتصدعه حتى الان لا توجد احصاءات دقيقه
حول هذه البيوت ولا توجد توصيات دقيقه
ايضا يعني ممكن ان يكون هناك بيوت خطره
الناس مطالبون بعدم العوده اليها وهناك
بيوت تتم ازالتها كما حدث في بثانيا يوم
امس عندما قامت سلطات المعارضه بتدمير
مبنى ايه لسقوط ووضعه خطر خوفا من ان يعود
سكانه اليه لكن هناك بيوت اضرارها بسيطه
حتى الان نقابه المهندسين السوريين
التابعه المعارضه قالت بانها سوف تجري مسح
لهذه البيوت وتحدد الصالح منها للسكن وغير
الصالح لكن هذا الامر وهذا الاجراء ربما
ياخذ وقتا طويلا
ويتركوا اصحاب هذه البيوت في معاناه وفي
متاعب جمه في مراكز الايواء المتفرقه
ينتظرون وصول مساعدات اليهم لا يجرؤون على
الوصول الى بيوتهم او الرجوع الى اثاث
بيوتهم حتى يتم استخدامه في هذا الشتاء
وفي هذا البرد يبدو ان اجراءات نقابه
المهندسين سوف تاخذ طويلا وقتا طويلا
وتستمر معها معاناه سكان هذه البيوت
المتصدعه والمتضرره نعم